make no mistake about
it it's a criminal act against the fans
simple as that
you never hear from the owners of these
clubs it's pure greed
they're imposters they're nothing to do
with football in this country
they're an absolute joke and honestly
the time has come now
stop these clubs having the power base
enough is enough
and these are the six men gary neville
is speaking about the billionaire owners
of manchester united
manchester city arsenal tottenham
hotspur liverpool
and chelsea we hardly ever hear from
them but together with
six more of europe's richest clubs this
so-called
dirty dozen have schemed to execute a
breakaway which will reshape football
forever
a plot so audacious even the prime
minister is intervening
we're going to look at everything that
we can do
with the football authorities to make
sure that
this doesn't go ahead in the way that
it's currently being proposed i don't
think that it is
good news for for fans i don't think
it's good news for
for football in this country from
liverpool to tottenham and manchester
feelings were made absolutely clear the
imposters
they're leeching onto a club that fans
have been building for
over 100 years and they've just come in
sort the money out of it now they're
taking it away from the fans is probably
the worst thing that has happened in
that i can think of in the last
maybe 50 years honestly it is
a disaster the new super league will
remove the threat of relegation for its
founding members and see more money
float to the top of the pyramid
they insist that money will filter back
down
but the uefa president says any players
involved will be banned from european
championships and world cups
football is an all-out civil war by my
opinion
this idea is a spit in the face
of all football lovers and our society
as well
so we will not allow them
to take it away from us the days when
community was the heartbeat of a
football club are long
gone but even so this league some
believe would take football further from
the reach of ordinary fans
it's just like they don't care they
don't understand that it's really
important to fans that there's a
authentic relationship with the club we
don't want to be consumers
we're actual supporters of a football
club and so there has to be
a two-way relationship there and
certainly
when this news came i think there was a
lot of anger because of that
players and coaches felt compelled to
defend the super league
in the absence of their paymasters who
were nowhere to be seen
as you know i'm i'm part of this club i
want to play these card competitions and
i trust my club
to make the right decisions and i think
it's
too early to judge everything there have
been suggestions that this is just a
game of brinkmanship
i've spoken to people closely involved
with the super league
they say this is very real it's
happening
and the main aim is to grow the pie so
everyone can enjoy
the 14 premier league clubs left behind
will meet tomorrow without the six
rebels
to discuss how they respond to the
gauntlet laid down for them
they believe the pie is being made
bigger but only so the select few can
feast on its riches
martha kellner sky news